here's what i say when a prospect says
hey i'm too busy or now's not a good
time let me wait till later to start
doing this thing i say listen let's be
real there's always going to be another
thing that's coming up because now it's
christmas then it's new year's then it's
easter then it's getting ready for
spring and there's always going to be
another thing and then it's going to be
tuesday's donuts at the office at the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
because the thing is is that the harder
the season that you're about to enter
the more realistic it is that if we get
you through that you'll be able to
encounter the next one because if you
can only be successful in perfect
seasons then we already know that this
is not going to last for the long run
and you said you want to do this for the
long term so if you want to make this
change sustainable and you want to make
it for good we got to start now and we
got to get through the hardest period so
that we know that you're going to stick
with it for good